shaun manaya guy who's been tough on the
mariners since 2018 he's won four of his
last five starts against the mariners
pitching to a one two three e-r-a so
here's kyle seeger the veteran
and here's the delivery now and
cigarettes the tapper to the right side
charged at first olson has it flipping
mania is there in the bag
and 3-1 on seeger and that's it for the
mariners hanegar left at second seattle
fails to score
with the a's coming up in the bottom now
tyler anderson
6-9 on the year of 4.14 eras throwing
152 innings matt olsen having a fine
year hitting 276 36 home runs and 103
runs batted in
anderson ready the wind up and again the
o2 pitch swinging a jam shot ground ball
right to france at first base underhand
flipped anderson covering first on the
play to get olson and that's it for the
ace and the bottom of the first nice
start that'll bring up abraham toro
here's the 1-2 delivery now swung out of
miss off speed up and away a foul tip
held by gomes
champion hitting just 222 26 home run 71
runs batted in strikes out a lot
anderson doesn't waste any time
left-handed ready the wind-up and the o2
on the way and here she comes swaying
enemies for strike three and tyler
anderson has his first strikeout of the
night quack quack the organ duck strikes
out matt chapman one away for the a's
so one away for oakland that'll bring up
catcher john gomes
the 3-2 on the way swaying and a miss at
a pitch down and away for strike three
so back-to-back strikeouts for
tyler anderson quack quack again for the
oregon duck strikes out chapman strikes
out gomes
and two away for the athletics here in
the bottom half of any number two with
no score in the ball game anderson off
to a fine start mckenna batting 235 17
home runs
and 57 runs batted in
canada back in there the wind up and the
3-2 pitch here she comes swing and i
miss for strike three and tyler anderson
quack quack quack strikes out the side
here in the bottom of the second the
oregon duck off to a fantastic start in
the first two innings he's retired
six in a row we go to the top of the
third marine is in the a's no score
runners at the corners here in the third
inning and ty france coming up he's the
10th leading hitter in the american
league entering tonight's action
pulled into left field the mariners
take an early lead on an rbi base hit
from tai france dylan moore scores
and it's one nothing in the top of the
third what a great setup for kyle seeger
one out base is loaded
[Music]
out towards left center field and this
drops in bounces high off the wall
crawford in
france right behind him haniger a wide
turn he gets back to the bag he's safe
at third
kyle seeger brings home two he stands up
at second of the mariners lead mania and
the a's three nothing in the third
inning
so a rough heading for mania
and now facing luis terence
swinging in a miss he struck him out a
huge strikeout
now toro struck out his first time up
three balls the two strikes the pitch
swung on fly ball to left and cannon has
a play
mark waiting for it
and he will make a one-handed catch in
the end is over but seattle strikes
first
they bat eight and score three times and
on to the bottom of the third it is
three-nothing seattle and now here's kd
chris davis batting 200 two homers and
seven rbis including his time with
the texas rangers
as an athletic he's gone eight for 29
three doubles
and two
rbis one has driven to right center
field nobody's going to get this one
so this is going to be an rbi double as
pinder comes in to score davis just in
ahead of the tag and it's three to one
but here comes another dangerous hitter
starling martay first pitch to martay
swing on hit to jp crawford nice job by
anderson to get the final out as jp
throws over plenty of time now two gone
and here comes jp crawford
oh and to the count look at first the
pitch
breaking ball a wave and a miss down go
the mariners in the fourth they get a
single and nothing more on the home half
it's 3-1 seattle i'll see her with a
double drove in a couple runs his last
time up
he rips this in a right center field
hannigar's coming around seeger drives
in his third run tonight and he is out
at second base davis one for one with an
rbi double here's the three two
swing enemies strike three there is
strikeout number four for tyler anderson
two outs for the ace
so here's anderson
in good shape here in the six he's got
matt olsen right now over two grand out
the first and fly to right here's the o2
drops down sidearm swinging in a missing
breaking ball got him fifth strikeout
for tyler anderson
chapman tonight struck out 102 pitch
walked in a full count in the fourth
inning
pitch swaying and a miss and a fastball
top of the zone comes up empty great job
by anderson as hanukkah stands in he's
been on base three times two doubles
and a walk and a run
and he scored
it
it's a good change up from acevedo so
he's done a nice job in his two innings
of work
brings up mark canna
and comes to the plate breaking ball
swung on and miss canna goes down on
strikes one away
and that is strikeout number seven for
anderson he struck out three of the last
four that he's faced
well here's marty
he's dying for a hit right now
he's bounced out three times
mariners four is one
one out runners at the corners bottom of
the eighth
now seattle's going to play the infield
for two
and the fish to starling by castillo now
and it's a ground ball into right for a
base hit that'll score elvis harrison's
around second sliding there gets back to
the bag put on the brakes and marta
delivers the base hit to right and these
are very much alive it's 4-2 seattle 2-1
and two outs one run in mariners lead
4-2 and here is matt chapman
here's the stretch and the right-handers
0-2 pitch fastball swing and a miss
strike three paul seawall strikes out
matt chapman and the oakland a's leave
the time run stranded and first and
second here in the bottom of the eighth
inning seth brown will pinch it for
pender
and the one-two pitch back door slider
strike three called got him looking
brown strikes out for the final out of
the ball game what a performance by paul
seawall as the mariners beat the a's
here in oakland a final score off
fortitude to take the opening game of
the four game set and right here right
now the mariners are three games back in
the wild card race